es una tragedia casi diaria
constantemente y diría yo que casi todos
los días se reporta la llegada aquí al
reino unido- de embarcaciones de
personas que cruzan todos los días
tratando de encontrar una mejor vida
aquí en el reino unido según cifras que
se han conocido sólo en noviembre en un
solo día mil migrantes llegaron a este
país tratando de buscar asilo lo cierto
es que no todo se les garantiza esta
posibilidad y también en lo que va
corrido de este
2021 25.000 personas han cruzado el
canal de la mancha algunas voces han
sugerido hoy que es hora de que france
el reino unido deje de recriminarse
mutuamente por quien hace y quien lo
hace y que empiecen a trabajar de manera
conjunta para evitar esta tragedia
creciente